I used to set a PTA meetings with Elvis
right he'd sit there in a little change
you're being serious yeah an Elvis would
show up to the PTA meeting in a cape
John Thomas died
he'd show up in a cave yes
and he'd say I loved him why do they
look at me Miss Joan and I once said
Don't wear a velvet cake
dude maybe you take the cape off for the
parent teacher conference no kidding
look at me
he would really go to the school and sit
there okay
with him yes the Memphis Mafia and Eddie
the drama you should have taken pictures
of that it all came to the birthday
party it was her excuse me excuse me Mr
Presley uh it's not Halloween you can
take over your costume yeah there's no
costume they used to come and the other
one the Carpenters came to Melissa's
birthday party she would come to
Melissa's birthday party because we had
the same manager would she sing at
Melissa's parties no but she would sing
at Christmas Christmas party yeah oh
yeah that's some Christmas party oh
please I've been to that Christmas party
there's no food I'm changing it out of
Thanksgiving
now listen to me you're telling me the
Carpenters would show up at your
daughter's birthday yes and sing for
your daughter not singer but we all
gather around the piano I'm not stupid
and what would she sing like like close
to you oh just that no kidding man you
mean you know a lot of famous people I
know a lot of she was there at every
point in history I'm completely
flabbergasted by Elvis going to PTA
meetings in a cave he was a great father
oh I know I'm here for the
parent-teacher conference the funny
thing is Lisa Marie didn't go to that
school yeah Elvis was in the wrong he
was at Melissa's School Janet Lee she
was ahead of us but you know the parents
janetly and she's so gorgeous with the
big breasts and married she would go for
Jamie Lee Curtis's Teachers Conference
and Mrs dye who ran John Thomas die he
said tell her to put on a high neck
dress she'd show up with her big boobs
thinking out that's funny yeah it was a
great school it's a fabulous School
foreign